here we go after emigrating from Spain
to Australia in her 20s
Monica Pro worked as a carer now with
advanced dementia she's the one who
needs looking after after her husband
Silvio had a stroke both needed
full-time care in a nursing home but in
one staff responded to pros behavior by
sedating her with drugs lots of them
physically she was losing a balance
she was blank-faced she was pretty much
screaming a lot of the time I couldn't
help her you know because of the drugs
in her system she couldn't help herself
I could nobody could help her every day
was a struggle only after two years of
slowly weaning her off the drugs and
paying for extra private nursing staff
does her son feel his mother is calm so
the mother that I see today when I hug
her even though she has dementia I feel
like she's my mother you know and I and
I feel this strength and I feel I feel
her peace Monica pro is experience is
far from unique Human Rights Watch has
investigated aged care centers across
Australia and found what they call
chemical restraint is often the norm
caring for people with dementia is labor
intensive and that's expensive drugs are
a cheaper alternative but often given
without informed consent from the
patient or their relatives Human Rights
Watch says it's a violation of their
rights I do think that most people would
be shocked to find that it's a common
practice to drug older people mostly
people with dementia really makes no
sense to say that there should be a
lower standard for drugging someone in
order to control their behavior as
compared to perhaps using some sort of
physical restraint the issue is not
unique to Australia Human Rights Watch
also investigated in the United States
and found chemical restraint there was
just as common but in Australia at the
moment a national inquiry a Royal
Commission is looking into issues right
across the country's aged care system
cases of abuse neglect and a routine
lack of respect for the elderly are all
being uncovered and exposed there is
national contemplation that the way
people are treated towards the ends of
their lives Andrew Thomas al-jazeera
Melbourne